Metro Police releasing the body cam
footage of last week's officer-involved
shooting Metro Police say officers were
on a Stakeout for robbery suspect near
Valley View and Flamingo police say 48
year old Matthew glent is a suspect in a
string of robberies and has an extensive
criminal history when officers attempted
to take him into custody he fired at
them leading to them to return fire
at that time glunt discharged his
firearm towards officers
this action prompted detective
Christopher Gowens and officer Joshua
Leach to discharge their firearms
striking glunt several times
no officer was injured glunt was taken
to the hospital for his injuries and
he's facing several charges including
burglary and attempted murder on a
police officer that